- [Announcer:] WILDCARD WEEKEND...
Choose your matchup.
- My stats are almost as good as Watt's!
- [Announcer:] Browns/Texans: FIGHT!
- Get over here.
- [Announcer:] Steelers/Bills: FIGHT!
- Press "B" all you want, I’m NOT blocking.
- Careless... SLIDE!
- [Announcer:] Packers/Cowboys: FIGHT!
- As a Packers QB...
I eventually turn into a monster.
- [Announcer:] PLEASE ENTER CeeDee.
- Uh-oh...
- [Announcer:] Rams/Lions: FIGHT!
- Eat Kneecaps!
- JERSEY... SWAP!!!
- [Announcer:] EAGLES/BUCS: FIGHT!
- Tush Push! T-T-Tush Push! Tush Push!
- Stop spamming that one f--king move.
- [Announcer:] DOLPHINS/CHIEFS: LOCKED!
Enter friend’s Peacock password.
- Can't. Perform. So. Cold.
- [Announcer:] TEXANS WIN!
- Why...won't...you...just...die...
Whoaaa--
- [Announcer:] BILLS ADVANCE!
- Wait, that was a playoff game?
- Love bomb!
- Ugh!
- [Announcer:] PACKERS WIN!
- Here we go.
- [Announcer:] LIONS WIN!
- [Lions fans chanting:] Jared Goff! Jared Goff!
- [Announcer:] OH DEAR LORD. CUT AWAY.
- [Announcer:] EAGLES DEFEAT THEMSELVES!
- What a f--king meltdown.
- Speedy Hill!
- THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME I'VE FROZEN OUT MY BROTHER.
- [Announcer:] FLAWLESS VICTORY.
- DIE, DIE, DIE.
- BYE WEEK MEANS UNLIMITED SCREEN TIME!
- [Announcer:] AND FLACCO’S ATTACK IS COMING BACK THE OTHER WAY…
AGAIN!
LIONS FANS CRYING TEARS OF JOY…
SENTIMENTALITY!
PRESS “A” TO CHASE TOMLIN OUT OF THE PRESS CONFERENCE!
- [Journalist:] Mike, Mike! You have one year left on your contract! Mike!
- [Announcer:] Baker, finish him!
- [Baker:] Sirianni? Hurts?
Who do you mean?
- My dad's here, bye!
- Alright, see you in Vegas.